- Hey, how can I help you?
What is that?
BRANDON: I think it's a
Le Testophone French horn.
To be honest, I haven't seen
one of these things before,
but it looks like something
right out of Dr. Seuss.
Looks like a car horn to me.
I guess it could
have been used
on a car, or more looks like
something of a calliope, maybe.
Don't you think it
would be built better?
Maybe like a horse horn?
We're all in
agreement it's a horn.
[horn sounds]
BRANDON: Today, I
brought into the pawnshop
on antique French horn.
I'm selling the horn
today because I can't
really do anything with it.
I thought it was cool, but
I can't put it anywhere.
So I'll see if I can
get some money for it.
The horn I'm bringing is not
in the greatest condition,
but I'm hoping that
that doesn't matter just
because it's so old and unique.
That is definitely cool.
What you have here
is a really bizarre
horn that might have been used
on really high-end automobiles.
When they first came out with
cars, they didn't have horns.
Even up to the 1950s, it
was sort of the thing to get
aftermarket horns put on cars.
Is there a date on it anywhere?
BRANDON: Well, I had 1942.
It wouldn't have been 1942.
And the reason why, in 1942,
France was occupied by Germany.
They were not
making fancy horns.
They were making only
war-related items.
And we were definitely not
importing anything from them
because it was Nazi
Germany at the time,
and we weren't doing
business with them.
What did you want to do with it?
BRANDON: I want to sell it.
And how much do
you want for it?
BRANDON: $1,000.
And how'd you get that price?
BRANDON: I looked it up online,
and I seen a few that were--
looked similar like that.
So I thought, hey.
It wouldn't surprise
me if one of these things
would go for $1,000
in great shape.
This thing is a world
away from great shape.
That's your problem.
You have a horn
right here that's
missing and soldered over.
Obviously, there was a
hole or something right
here happened, because they
put a bunch of lead solder
over the top of it.
It's rusted.
It's bent.
It's broken.
And in great shape, I
imagine there's a possibility
that it could go for $1,000.
In this shape, nothing.
But unfortunately,
it's not for me, man.
BRANDON: OK.
- All right.
Thanks for bringing
it in, though.
BRANDON: No problem.
Thank you.
Chum, help some customers.
[music playing]
BRANDON: Well, I was a
little disappointed that he
didn't even make an offer.
So I'm going to
actually take it.
I'm going to put
it online, and I'm
sure someone's going to, you
know, take it off my hands.